in the pouring rain
people come to see what happened or
salvage what's left
the makeshift homes built from plastic
sheets and bamboo poles had no
chance when this muddy hillside
collapsed in torrential rains
my sister went to the bathroom and after
she returned the side of the hill came
down
i have one niece and two nephews and my
sister my brother-in-law along with the
other family members
managed to get out of the shelter but
the cliff came down on those four
and the entire shelter was damaged two
of them died and two others were injured
the powerful monsoon rains caused a
flood that reached roof
height in some areas of the kutapalong
camp
more than 100 tents are said to have
been washed away by the water
kutapalong in bangladesh is the world's
biggest refugee camp
and the most densely populated it's home
to more than one million rohingya
who fled a crack down by the military in
neighboring myanmar
it's overcrowded basic and prone to
landslides and flooding
we have informed the people at risk here
to move away if they do not comply with
our request
we will take alternate steps since it's
raining so much
we hope the rohingya population at the
camp will move away
from risky dwellings the government says
all the rohingya will be resettled as
soon as possible
and that measures are being taken to
minimise casualties caused by the annual
reigns
but rights groups say it's not enough
and that the floods prove
once more how vulnerable the rohingya
refugees are to the impacts of climate
change
many are now sheltering in mosques in
schools and facing the prospect of
having lost their homes
again alexia o'brien al jazeera